IT'S TIME FOR WALKING DEAD
SPOILERS.
WALKING DEAD SPOILERS.
THE WALKING DEAD RIPPED
OUR GODDAMN HEARTS OUT OF
OUR CHEST AND KILLS OFF
MAJOR CHARACTERS, TWO IN THE
LAST TWO EPISODES ALONE.
WHEN YOU WERE WORK
ON A SHOW LIKE THIS I TRY TO
PROTECT MYSELFS, YOU HAVE TO
KEEP ALL THE INFORMATION IN
YOUR HEADS ALL THE TIME AND
BE CONSCIOUS NOT TO SCREW UP.
SO I WANT TO FREE YOU BY
LETTING YOU GIVE ME AS MANY
FAKE SPOILERS FOR THE NEW
SEASON OF THE WALKING DEAD
AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN.
IT WILL BE FUN.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I AM GOING TO PUT OF 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK AND BEGIN.
LAUREN.
>> CARL HAS BEEN WEARING A
WIRE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
KIRKMAN.
>> MAGGIE AND EUGENE BOTH
DIE IN NEXT WEEK'S EPISODE.
>> CHRIS: WHOA!
POINTS.
>> BRIAN WILLIAMS ADMITS HE
REALLY WASN'T IN THE CDC
WHEN IT BLEW UP.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
>> MISHAWNA HAS BEEN PLAYED
BY YOU CHRIS HARDWICK THIS
WHOLE TIME.
>> CHRIS: YES.
JOSH.
>> BETH COMES BACK AS A DOG
THAT CAN SOLVE CRIMES.
>> GREAT.
>> CHRIS: WAIT A MINUTE.
WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS DOG IS STILL GOING TO
SING SONGS, RIGHT.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
>> CHRIS: OKAYING POINTS.
KIRKMAN.
>> EVENTUALLY A CHARACTER
NAMED NEGAN IS INTRODUCED
AND WILL BASH IN GLENN'S
BRAINS WITH A BASEBALL BAT
CALLED LUCILLE.
>> OH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> IT'S A COMEDY SHOW.
JOSH.
>> THE GANG GETS A VISIT
FROM THE HARLEM GLOBETROTTERS.
>> CHRIS: SO GOOD.
POINTS.
KIRKMAN.
>> THE GROUP STUMBLES ACROSS
A WORKING CHILI, SITS DOWN
FOR A NICE MEAL AND ENJOYS
THE PREMIER EPISODE OF THE A
M.C. CLASSIC "LOW WINTER SUN."